Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. This story shall the good man teach his son, and Crispin Crispian shall ne'er go by from this day to the ending of the world, but we in it shall be remembered, we few, we happy few, we band of brothers,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家播客番外、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入会员。网址是 therestishistory.com。此段故事，慈父当教之令子，自今日直到世界之尽头，克里斯平与克里斯皮安之日决不虚度，而我们亦将名垂青史——我们这寥寥数人，我们这幸运的少数，我们这生死同袍；
for he today that sheds his blood with me shall be my brother. Be he ne'er so vile, this day shall gentle his condition, and gentlemen in England now abed shall think themselves accursed they were not here, and hold their manhoods cheap whilst any speaks that fought with us upon St Crispin's Day. That is stirring stuff, Tom. It's the most famous speech on a battlefield ever written. One of the most famous speeches in English history, or in English literary history anyway. It's Henry V at the Battle of Agincourt.
因为今日与我同袍洒血之人，即为我兄弟。无论他身份何等卑微，今日之后，他的地位必将高贵。如今滞留英格兰卧榻之上的绅士，必将痛恨自己未能亲临此地，每当有人提及曾与我们在圣克里斯平节并肩作战，他们便会自惭形秽。这番话真令人热血沸腾，汤姆。这是有史以来最著名的战前演说。至少是英国历史上，或者说英国文学史上最著名的演说之一。这就是《亨利五世》中阿金库尔战役的场景。
I know you love the Kenneth Branagh version. You've been watching it on a loop on YouTube to inspire yourself for today's episode on Agincourt. I know you love the Kenneth Branagh version. You've been watching it on a loop on YouTube to inspire yourself for today's episode on Agincourt. Branagh does it brilliantly, doesn't he? He does it with a kind of rising lilt. He does. And his production, I remember at the time, his production was seen as a groundbreaking, a film version, because it broke with the sort of technicolor, slightly manicured look of Olivier's Henry V. And he was down in the mud, wasn't he? A soldier among soldiers. Yeah, so Olivier's one was very deliberately done as being patriotic. It was made in 1944. All the awkward bits in Shakespeare's play that
我知道你很喜欢肯尼思·布拉纳的版本。为了给今天关于阿金库尔战役的节目寻找灵感，你一直在优酷上单曲循环观看它。我知道你很喜欢肯尼思·布拉纳的版本。为了给今天关于阿金库尔战役的节目寻找灵感，你一直在优酷上单曲循环观看它。布拉纳演得太精彩了，不是吗？他带着一种抑扬顿挫的语调。确实如此。而且我记得当时他的制作被视为一种突破性的电影版本，因为它打破了劳伦斯·奥利弗版《亨利五世》那种特艺七彩（Technicolor）且略显雕琢的视觉风格。他深入泥泞之中，对吧？宛如士兵之中的一员。是的，奥利弗的版本非常刻意地突出了爱国主义色彩。那是1944年拍摄的。莎士比亚戏剧中所有那些令人尴尬的片段——
makes Henry V as a hero slightly ambivalent were cut. And Branagh's, as you say, I mean, there's lots of mud, there's lots of rain which is very authentic to the actual battle but in that speech he really goes in hard it's absolutely thrilling and you know we've talked about this before it's undoubtedly the reason why agincourt blazes in the imagination of the english perhaps more brightly than any other victory won by an English army. Yeah, I think that's true. But it's not just down to Shakespeare. So it's clear right from the beginning, long before Shakespeare, that the English do see Agincourt as being exceptional in a way that
让亨利五世作为英雄略显矛盾的片段都被删掉了。而布拉纳的版本，正如你所说，里面有很多泥泞，有很多雨水，这非常符合真实的战斗。但在那段演讲中，他真的倾注了全力，绝对扣人心弦。正如我们以前讨论过的，毫无疑问，这就是为什么阿金库尔战役在英国人心中燃烧的想象之火，比英国军队赢得的任何其他胜利都要炽烈。是的，我想确实如此。但这并不完全归功于莎士比亚。因为早在莎士比亚之前，从一开始就很明显，英国人确实认为阿金库尔战役与众不同，这是
neither Cressy nor Poitier had been. And in Henry V, that great speech, which you read so powerfully, Dominic, is prompted by a lament from one of Henry's peers from Westmoreland that they're terribly outnumbered. So Westmoreland, he's looking out at the French and he says, oh, that we now had here but one 10,000 of those men in England that do no work today. And Henry replies, I pray thee, wish not one man more. If we die, that's, you know, we don't want any more. And if we win, then the glory is all the greater. And the thing is that Shakespeare is not making this up. So this is reported by the chaplain, who is one of the two combatants on the English side who have written accounts of Agincourt. And the chaplain
克雷西或普瓦捷战役所不具备的。而在《亨利五世》中，多米尼克，你饱含激情朗诵的那段伟大的演说，是由亨利的一位同僚——威斯特摩兰伯爵的一声叹息引发的，他感叹他们的人数实在太少了。威斯特摩兰望着法军，说道：“唉，但愿如今在这里的，不仅有今天在英格兰无所事事的那些人中的一万名就好了。”亨利回答道：“我求你，莫再奢望多一个人。如果我们阵亡，那——你知道的，我们不需要更多人。如果我们获胜，那么荣耀也就愈发伟大。”关键是，莎士比亚并不是凭空捏造这一情节的。这是由随军牧师记录下来的，他是参与阿金库尔战役并留下文字记载的仅有的两名英方参战者之一。这位牧师
reports a knight as making the same complaint that Westmoreland makes in Shakespeare's play. And Henry's retort, according to his chaplain, is, I would not, even if I could, have a single man more than I do. But there's a slightly different kind of emphasis in Henry's words, as reported by the chaplain. Because Henry says, do you not believe that the almighty, with these his humble few, is able to overcome the opposing arrogance of the French who boast of their great number and their own strength? So the emphasis there is on the idea that the victory proves God's backing for Henry.
记录了一位骑士发出了与莎士比亚戏剧中威斯特摩兰相同的抱怨。而据其牧师记载，亨利的回答是：“即便可以，我也不愿增加哪怕一个人。”不过，牧师所记录的亨利的话，其侧重点略有不同。因为亨利说：“难道你们不相信，全能的上帝凭借这区区数人，就足以战胜法国人自恃人多势众、狂妄自大的傲慢吗？”所以，这里的重点在于这场胜利证明了上帝对亨利的支持。
And this is clearly hugely important to Henry because the battle for him is a kind of test. He's putting his claim to the French throne in the balance. And isn't it interesting how those themes that are hit both by the chaplain's account and by Shakespeare, they resonate so deeply in English history. The idea of the humble few against a massively superior army, the arrogance of the French, all of that kind of thing. I mean, you've got the band of brothers that we mentioned before that Nelson was inspired by, the idea of the few that obviously,
这显然对亨利至关重要，因为这场战役对他而言是一场试炼。他将自己对法国王位的继承权押注在天平之上。你不觉得很有趣吗？无论是牧师的记录还是莎士比亚的戏剧，其中所触及的主题在英国历史上引起了如此深远的共鸣。以微末之众对抗压倒性优势的敌军、法国人的傲慢，诸如此类。我的意思是，我们之前提到的生死同袍（band of brothers），纳尔逊曾从中获得灵感，还有纳粹德国时期丘吉尔等人显然也利用过的“少数人”的概念。
you know, Churchill and whatnot played with in the Second World War. But at the time, I guess that also reflects a wider political, geographical reality that France is much larger, economically more powerful, has far greater manpower than England. So the English, the sense of themselves as being the underdogs, it's very Russia and Ukraine or something, isn't it? They've launched an incursion into the enemy territory. They're massively outnumbered, but they are absolutely convinced
但在当时，我想这也反映了一个更广泛的政治与地理现实：法国体量庞大得多，经济实力更强，人力资源远超英格兰。因此，英国人认为自己是弱势群体，这非常类似于俄乌冲突之类的情况，不是吗？他们对敌方领土发动了突袭。他们寡不敌众，但他们绝对坚信
that right and justice are on their side, even though presumably the people living in the surrounding French villages might see things rather differently. Yeah, might have a slightly different perspective. But they capitalise on it, as we will see. So they benefit from it too. It also reflects the fact that clearly for the English, when they crest this hill, which we described at the end of the last episode, and they look out and they see the French forces in front of them, it's terrifying. So again, to quote Henry's chaplain, he sees the French cavalry
正义站在自己一边，尽管周围法国村庄里的居民可能有着截然不同的看法。是的，他们可能会有略微不同的视角。但正如我们将看到的，他们利用了这一点。所以他们也从中获益。这也反映出一个事实：显而易见，对于英国人来说，当他们翻过我们在上一集结尾所描述的那座小山，放眼望去，看到眼前的法军时，那是极其骇人的。所以，再次引用亨利牧师的话，他看到法国骑兵
thundering from all directions to block their path. And he says they're like a countless swarm of locusts. And he has no doubt that the English are absolutely massively outnumbered. So he says their numbers, the numbers of the French, were so great as not to be even comparable with ours. And of course, he and Henry and everybody in the force is aware that there are other reasons why the English are not in peak fighting form, because they have travelled 250 miles in 17 days from Harfleur to the Somme, down the length of the Somme because the bridges and the fords and the causeways have been held against them, and then back up again. And the corollary in turn of that is that they haven't eaten properly for several days because Henry had only taken supplies for eight days. The weather is terrible, kind of icy sleet. It's become very hilly, so they've been going up and
从四面八方雷霆般冲来，阻断他们的去路。他说他们就像无数的蝗虫。他毫不怀疑英军在绝对数量上处于极度劣势。因此他说，法军的人数之多，简直无法与我们相提并论。当然，他和亨利以及军中的所有人都清楚，英军不在巅峰状态还有其他原因，因为他们从哈勒夫尔到索姆河，沿着索姆河全长走了17天，行程250英里，因为桥梁、浅滩和堤道都被敌人把守着，然后他们又折返回来。随之而来的结果是，他们已经好几天没有吃顿饱饭了，因为亨利只带了八天的口粮。天气糟糕透了，下着冰冷的雨夹雪。地形变得丘陵起伏，所以他们一直在上山下
down. So that's kind of more tiring than just marching across flat land. And I think it's clear when they see that force in front of them, they are feeling very demoralized. The feeling that, you know, this is it, this is absolute curtains. But I do think that there is certainly one man in that army who does think, you know, we have a chance here. And that man is Henry himself. This is where individuals matter, right? The we have a chance here. And that man is Henry himself. This is where individuals matter, right? The individuals do matter in war. And this is why leadership and inspirational command really makes a difference.
山。这比单纯在平地上行军要劳累得多。我想很明显，当他们看到眼前的这支军队时，他们感到士气极其低落。那种感觉，你知道的，就是“完了，这下彻底没救了”。但我确实认为，那支军队里肯定有一个人觉得：“你知道吗，我们在这里还有机会。”那个人就是亨利本人。这就是个人发挥作用的地方，对吧？个人的确在战争中发挥作用，这就是为什么领导力和鼓舞人心的统帅才能真正产生影响。
And it's why I think you can look at Shakespeare's play and say he burnishes Henry's reputation with this incredible poetry. But I do think that Henry clearly deserves his reputation as an astonishing military commander with an ability to inspire people who otherwise might just have turned into a kind of despairing rabble. So everybody sees, he feels no despair seeing the French army. So again, the chaplain describes Henry observing the French very calmly and quite heedless of danger. He orders his men to dismount, to ready themselves for battle. Remember, he's ordered them to wear their armour, to wear their surcoats, to indicate the fact that they are ready for battle,
这也是为什么我认为你可以审视莎士比亚的戏剧，并说他用这惊艳的诗篇擦亮了亨利的声誉。但我确实认为，亨利显然当得起他那惊人军事统帅的声誉，他有能力鼓舞那些原本可能变成绝望乌合之众的人。因此，所有人都能看到，他在看到法军时没有感到丝毫绝望。同样，牧师描述亨利非常平静地观察着法国人，对危险浑然不觉。他命令手下下马，做好战斗准备。记住，他曾命令他们穿上盔甲、穿上罩袍，以表明他们随时准备战斗，
no matter when it happens. He clearly stays on horseback. He rides along the battlefront. He gives his stirring speech. So he tells them that they should have a fair day and a gracious victory in the better of their enemies. He states bluntly, I am not going to be captured. You know, if there is a defeat, then I will die in the battle rather than impose the burden of a ransom on the English. And it's at this point, not as in Shakespeare on the eve of the battle, that he makes his comment about not wanting any more men. You know what, this is very Theoden at the charge of the Rehirim before Minas Tirith or something, isn't it? The spectacle of the king on his horse and his men lined up before him and him genuinely infusing them with a sense of mission and a sense of inevitability, I guess, is what he gives them. I think absolutely. He's clearly a very inspirational speaker, but the difference is that he doesn't then launch a great charge because he assumes that they are going to be
无论何时发生。他显然留在了马背上。他沿着战线骑马巡视。他发表了激昂的演说。所以他告诉他们，在战胜敌人时，他们将迎来美好的一天和荣耀的胜利。他直言不讳地说：“我绝不会被俘。你知道的，如果战败，我宁愿战死沙场，也不愿把赎金的重担强加给英格兰。”正是在这个时候——而不是像莎士比亚所写的那样在战前夕——他发表了关于不再需要更多人的言论。你知道吗，这简直就像米那斯提力斯之战前夕洛汗骑士冲锋时的希奥顿王，对吧？国王骑在马背上、部下列队其前的壮观景象，他真诚地向他们灌输了一种使命感，我想，还有一种历史必然感，这就是他带给他们的。我绝对这么认为。他显然是一个极具感染力的演讲者，但不同的是，他并没有随即发起大规模冲锋，因为他认为他们当天将要
facing battle that day. So he orders the priests to move through the lines, to take people's confessions. The English kneel down with their hands towards heaven. And there are French accounts of the battle that they're impressed by this. So this has been a theme running throughout the march that Henry is kind of inspiring his men to share in his own sense of a divine purpose. I think quite different to the, you know, the chevauchee that the Black Prince or Edward III or Duke of Lancaster were launching in the first half. Henry is a very, very devout man. And it's not a kind of hand-wringing, thought-for-the-day kind of Christianity. It's a martial, smite them, God is on our side kind of Christianity. And it clearly inspires the English. So they are down kneeling, praying, asking for God's blessing. But having done this, the French are not offering battle. No sign of movement at all from the army in front of them. Henry keeps the English in battle formation. And when he sees the French
面对一场恶战。于是他命令神父们穿梭于阵列之间，听取士兵们的忏悔。英格兰士兵双手合十，跪倒在地。法国方面的战史记录也对此印象深刻。因此，亨利激励手下分享他那种神圣使命感的信念，贯穿了整个行军过程。我认为这与黑太子、爱德华三世或兰开斯特公爵在前半段发动的骑兵劫掠截然不同。亨利是一个非常非常虔诚的人。这绝不是那种优柔寡断、空谈一日灵修式的基督教。这是一种尚武的、痛击敌人的、上帝站在我们这一边的基督教。这显然极大地鼓舞了英国人。因此他们跪倒在地，祈祷并寻求上帝的保佑。然而，在做完这一切之后，法国人却迟迟不肯开战。正面的法军没有任何移动的迹象。亨利让英格兰人保持战斗队形。当他看到法国人
starting to kind of move, people drifting across, he shifts the line so that they are always facing the French ranks. But dusk is closing in. You know, it's cold, it's wet, it's getting dark. And it becomes clear that, you know, there is going to be no battle that day. The English can see the French kind of retiring to the nearby villages. So Agincourt is one of them. Rissauville is another. They're kind of settling down there. They're setting up their tents. Of course, I mean, that's agony for the English because they know that the French are going to be much better sheltered, much better fed. They're settling down there. They're setting up their tents. Of course, I mean, that's agony for the English because they know that the French are going to be much better sheltered, much better fed.
开始有所动作、有人四处游荡时，他便调整阵线，确保他们始终面对着法军的方阵。然而暮色渐沉。你知道的，天冷、地湿、天色渐暗。而且情况逐渐明朗：那天不会发生战斗了。英国人可以看到法国人正撤退到附近的村庄。阿金库尔是其中之一，里索维尔是另一个。他们开始在那里安顿下来，搭建帐篷。当然，我的意思是，这对英国人来说简直是煎熬，因为他们知道法国人将得到更好的庇护、更充裕的食物。他们开始在那里安顿下来，搭建帐篷。当然，我的意思是，这对英国人来说简直是煎熬，因为他们知道法国人将得到更好的庇护、更充裕的食物。
They're going to be regularly supplied. But the English stay in battle order until it's completely dark and they can no longer see the enemy. And it's only at dusk, which is about 4.40, that Henry finally stands his army down. The French have no urgency, right? Time is on their side. They will accumulate more men probably as time goes on
他们将获得源源不断的补给。但英国人一直保持着战斗队形，直到天色完全变黑，再也看不见敌人为止。直到大约傍晚4点40分的黄昏时刻，亨利才最终下令军队休整。法国人并不急于求成，对吧？时间站在他们这一边。随着时间的推移，他们可能会集结更多的人马，
and the English will become only more hungry, more tired, more wet, more miserable. French have no urgency, right? Time is on their side. They will accumulate more men probably as time goes on. And the English will become only more hungry, more tired, more wet, more miserable. Yeah. So actually, I mean, it's the French interest to delay as long as possible. Absolutely. And also more people will come in and join the French army because people are coming in from across northern France. But Henry is still on high alert. They are so close that they can see the French bonfires.
而英国人只会变得更加饥饿、疲惫、湿冷、悲惨。法国人并不急于求成，对吧？时间站在他们这一边。随着时间的推移，他们可能会集结更多的人马，而英国人只会变得更加饥饿、疲惫、湿冷、悲惨。是的。所以实际上，对法国人来说，尽可能拖延时间才符合他们的利益。绝对如此。而且还会有更多的人加入法军，因为人们正从法国北部各地赶来。但亨利依然高度戒备。他们离得如此之近，以至于能看到法国人的篝火，
They can hear them kind of chatting and talking. And again, it's one of the themes that is brilliantly used by Shakespeare and derives from authentic memories of the battle that rumours spread through the English ranks that the French are dicing over the prisoners that they're going to take the following day. That they are so confident of victory that they're already working out who's going to get what prisoner arrogance hubris tom well yes and so it's loud it's mouthy it's boastful the contrast again with the english ranks henry has imposed says i don't want to hear a word no one is to talk so all that stuff you get in shakespeare of henry kind of wandering around and people chatting and stuff. This doesn't happen. There is total silence.
能听到他们闲聊和说话的声音。同样，这也是莎士比亚巧妙运用并源自战役真实记忆的主题之一：谣言在英军阵营中流传，称法国人正在用骰子决定第二天要俘虏的那些战俘。他们对胜利如此自信，以至于已经在商量谁该分得哪个战俘了——傲慢，自大，汤姆。是的，所以这一切都显得喧闹、口无遮拦、吹嘘夸耀。与英军阵营形成鲜明对比的是，亨利下了严令：“我不想听到任何声音，任何人都不准说话。”所以你在莎士比亚作品中看到的那些亨利四处闲逛、人们闲聊的场景，并没有发生。这里是一片死寂。
And the reason for that is he wants to make it impossible for the French to launch a surprise attack by night. And of course, it's quite intimidating for the French. They wonder, have the English slipped away? What is the meaning of this terrifying, ominous silence? So the rain is bucketing down. The English soldiers try and find, you know, there are woods that they can shelter under the trees. There are kind of hedges, whatever. They try and get what shelter they can. Henry himself and his high command withdraw to a village in their rear called Maison Sel. They don't sleep there because they have a battle to plan. And around midnight, Henry sends a group of pick knights to go out and to scout out the battlefield, to work out the precise coordinates of the French lines. And when those knights come back and they deliver their report, then he and his high command finalise their battle plan. Henry does not sleep.
原因很简单，他要让法国人无法在夜间发动偷袭。当然，这也让法国人感到相当威慑。他们在猜想：英国人是不是已经溜走了？这恐怖而阴森的死寂究竟意味着什么？此时大雨倾盆而下。英格兰士兵试图寻找树林，在树下寻求庇护。还有各种篱笆之类的东西。他们尽其所能地寻找避雨之所。亨利本人和他的高级将领们则退回到后方一个名为梅藏塞勒的村庄。他们并没有在那里睡觉，因为他们还有一场战役需要筹划。大约在午夜时分，亨利派出一队精锐骑士外出侦察战场，摸清法军阵线的确切坐标。当这些骑士归来并汇报情况后，他和他的高级将领们最终敲定了作战计划。亨利没有睡觉，
His peers don't sleep. Instead, he is armoured and then fully armed. He hears three masses. So again, the sense that he's trusting in God. And then at dawn, as the sun rises, he puts on his helmet and his helmet has this crown kind of placed on the top. And the crown has the emblems of both England and France, bright gold. And this means that there will be no missing him in battle. Yeah. So all those Frenchmen who are looking to capture the king, they know exactly where he is.
他的将领们也没有睡觉。相反，他穿好盔甲，全副武装。他做了三场弥撒。这再次体现了他对上帝的笃信。随后在黎明时分，当太阳升起时，他戴上了头盔，头盔顶部放置了一顶王冠。这顶王冠带有英格兰和法国两国的标志，金光闪闪。这意味着在战场上绝不会有人错过他。是的。因此，所有那些寻找国王以期将其生擒的法国人，都能确切知道他在哪里。
And as we will see, this is very deliberate. Henry's not a man who would employ doubles, right? No, absolutely. And then in preparation for ordering his battle ranks, he doesn't climb onto a charger. He climbs onto a small gray horse. And I think this is so emblematic of his character. On the one hand, incredible degree of self-confidence, but at the same time, also this kind of Christian sense of humility fused into this idea of him on a small grey horse.
正如我们将看到的，这是非常刻意的。亨利可不是那种会使用替身的人，对吧？没错，绝对不是。随后，在准备整肃战阵时，他没有骑上高大的战马，而是骑上了一匹灰色的小马。我认为这极好地象征了他的性格。一方面，他有着惊人的自信；但与此同时，这种骑着灰小马的形象中，也融入了一种基督教式的谦逊。
He's drawing attention to the fact that he is humble as well as confident. Riding on the horse, he orders his men to take up their positions. So what is his plan? What is this strategy that he and his peers have been devising through the night? It's determined by two factors. And the first of these is the terrain, and the second is the makeup of his army. And both of them are quite distinctive. So the terrain first, they are on the road to Calais. The French have blocked them. And this road, the reason the French have blocked them where they are is that there's expanse of relatively flat fields.
他在向世人表明，自己既谦逊又自信。骑着马，他命令部下各就各位。那么他的计划是什么？他和将领们彻夜谋划的策略究竟是什么？这由两个因素决定，首先是地形，其次是军队的构成。这两者都相当独特。首先是地形，他们正处于通往加来（Calais）的路上。法国人挡住了他们的去路。法国人之所以把他们堵在这个地方，是因为这里有一片相对开阔的平地。
There is a slight dip. So between the French and the English, there's a slight declivity, which means that whoever is going to be attacking will have to kind of go down and then up. It's not steep, but it's a mild kind of gradient. Right. The fields have recently been ploughed. The soil here, it's not kind of light. It's not the kind of soil where rain would drain away easily. It's thick, heavy clay.
这里有一个微小的坡度。因此，在法军和英军之间有一个轻微的下坡，这意味着无论谁发起进攻，都必须先下坡再上坡。坡度并不陡峭，但属于缓坡。没错。这里的田地最近刚刚犁过。这里的土壤并不轻盈，也不是那种雨水能轻易渗走的土壤，而是厚重黏稠的黏土。
And that means that the ground is pretty sodden. Yeah. So that is something else that Henry is factoring into his plans for the battle. I mean, anyone who's read the Lady Bird book or something knows that Agincourt is a very muddy battle. Well, yes. I remember one of the first books I read on Agincourt was John Keegan's Face of Battle, which is about Agincourt, Waterloo and the Somme. And Agincourt and the Somme both have mud. They do indeed. As a kind of abiding theme. So there's this road, there's ploughed fields,
这意味着地面相当泥泞。是的，这也是亨利在制定作战计划时考虑到的另一个因素。我的意思是，任何读过《瓢虫书》（Lady Bird book）或类似读物的人都知道，阿金库尔是一场极其泥泞的战役。嗯，是的。我记得我读过的关于阿金库尔的第一本书是约翰·基根的《战役的面貌》（The Face of Battle），这本书讲述了阿金库尔、滑铁卢和索姆河战役。阿金库尔和索姆河都有泥泞。确实如此。作为一种挥之不去的主题。所以这里有一条路，有犁过的田地，
potentially very muddy. There are two villages on either side of the road and they're about a kilometre apart. So there's Agincourt on the left of the English as they're facing the French and there's a village called Tramacourt on the right. The battlefield is also bounded by woodland on both sides. And this woodland tapers in from the French positions.
可能非常泥泞。道路两侧各有一个村庄，相距约一公里。在英军面向法军的左侧是阿金库尔，右侧是一个叫特拉马库尔的村庄。战场两侧还被树林环绕。这片树林从法军阵地向内延伸，
I mean, again, not massively, but to a significant degree towards the English positions. So this is good for the English because, of course, they have far fewer men at arms. Maybe we'll come to the precise numbers, but I reckon around a thousand. And the French have many many many multiples of that so the fact that they can't be outflanked because there are the woods is very important and it also means that if the french advance towards the english there the ground in front of them will narrow there they will have to kind of crowd closer close together as they approach the english lines. Yes, it does. And so this then segues with the composition of Henry's forces to determine how he's going to kind of line up his ranks.
我的意思是，幅度虽不算巨大，但对英军阵地而言却起到了显著的收窄作用。这对英国人很有利，因为他们的重甲骑士要少得多。也许我们稍后会谈到确切的人数，但我估计大约有一千人。而法国人的兵力是他们的好几倍，因此由于有树林阻挡而不会被侧翼包抄，这一点至关重要。这也意味着，如果法军向英军推进，他们正前方的地面将会变窄，在逼近英军阵线时，他们将不得不更加紧密地挤在一起。是的，确实如此。这就与亨利军队的构成结合起来，决定了他将如何排兵布阵。
So it's conventional in battles in this period for armies to basically divide it into three positions. And Henry does this again. Normally, you'd have a front rank, you'd have a vanguard, you'd have a main body, and then you'd have a rear guard you'd have a vanguard you have a main body and then you'd have a rear guard yeah henry can't afford to do that he doesn't have enough men to do that so instead he draws them in a kind of line across this kilometer of open field between the woods on either side and the result is a kind of i suppose a thin silver line you might call it that's a thin red line yeah so henry it. I was about to say, a thin red line. So Henry commands the central division. And remember, he's got this gold crown.
在此期间的战役中，军队通常基本上分为三个阵位。亨利也采用了这种做法。通常情况下，你会设有一个前锋、一个先锋、一个主力，然后还有一个后卫。你会设有一个先锋、一个主力，然后还有一个后卫。是的，亨利无力做到这一点。他没有足够的人手这样做。因此，他把他们排成了一条横跨森林之间一公里开阔地的阵线，结果形成了一条——我想你可以称之为——银色细线。那是红色细线，对吧。所以亨利指挥中央师。记住，他戴着这顶金色王冠。
He's got his banner. There's no way the French are going to be able to miss him. He is in the middle of the middle division. On his right, he has a division commanded by the Duke of York, who is a close cousin of Henry's. He's a great fan of Chaucer. And perhaps not coincidentally, that being so, he's written a great famous treatise on hunting in English. So he's properly an English peer. And to Henry's left is the third division, which is commanded by a guy called
他带着他的军旗。法国人绝不可能错过他。他位于中央师的正中间。在他的右侧，是由约克公爵指挥的一个师，约克公爵是亨利的近亲。他是一位杰出的乔叟迷。也许并非巧合的是，正因如此，他用英文写了一篇关于狩猎的著名论文。所以他是一位根正苗红的英国贵族。在亨利的左侧是第三师，由一个名叫
Thomas Lord Camoys. And the reason that he's put in command is that he is 65. So he brings many, many years of experience. All three divisions consist of men at arms. So none of the English, not even the king, is going to be on horseback. But of course, the key decision for Henry is where he's going to place the main body of his army, which consists of archers. And the precise details of this is much debated. I mean, you can read multiple accounts of Agincourt and they all have slightly different sense of where it is. But I think the outline is pretty clear. Henry places large blocks of archers on both wings, kind of sheltered by trees in the woods, some of them. And he also positions them in wedges between
托马斯·卡莫伊斯勋爵的人指挥。之所以让他担任指挥官，是因为他已经65岁了。因此他带来了极为丰富的经验。这三个师都由重甲骑士组成。所以没有一个英国人（甚至包括国王在内）会骑马作战。当然，对亨利来说最关键的决定是，他要把由弓箭手组成的主力部队部署在哪里。关于其中的具体细节争议颇多。我的意思是，你可以读到多份关于阿金库尔战役的记录，它们对具体位置的描述略有不同。但我认为大致的轮廓非常清晰。亨利在两侧翼部署了大量弓箭手方阵，其中一些受到树林的庇护，同时他还将弓箭手以楔形阵势部署在
the three divisions. So in two wedges. And these are placed under another man who is very distinguished and really quite elderly. And this is a guy called Sir Thomas Irpingham, who is the most loyal of loyalist Lancastrians. His loyalty to Lancaster goes back to Henry IV before Henry became king. Thomas Irpingham had accompanied him on Crusade, where Henry picked up his ostrich and gone to Jerusalem and all that kind of thing. So Irpingham really is, I mean, properly seasoned. Oh, very much so. And completely reliable. So he was again with Henry in exile. He accompanies Henry back to England when he overthrows Richard II. So he's been with Henry in exile. He accompanies Henry back to England when he overthrows Richard II. So he's been there, he's seen everything. And the fact that he's now
三个师之间。具体来说是两个楔形阵。这些部队交由另一位杰出且年事已高的人物指挥，此人名叫托马斯·厄平汉爵士，他是兰开斯特家族最忠诚的忠臣。他对兰开斯特家族的忠诚可以追溯到亨利成为国王之前的亨利四世时期。托马斯·厄平汉曾陪同他参加十字军东征，亨利正是在那里获得了鸵鸟羽毛装饰并去了耶路撒冷等等。所以厄平汉真的可以说是身经百战。哦，确实如此。而且绝对可靠。因此他曾再次陪伴亨利流亡。当亨利推翻理查二世时，他陪同亨利返回英格兰。所以他经历过这一切，见证了一切。事实上，他现在
in command of the archers reflects the fact that Henry is putting a premium on experience. He wants people who he can absolutely rely on to hold his back and to do the right thing, even in conditions of incredible tension and danger. But at the same time, as Henry is emphasising experience, he's also not afraid to innovate. And so this is why on the march, he had ordered his archers, even though they were weary tired hungry to make themselves some wooden stakes sharp stakes and to carry them as well with everything else and this is something that edward iii's armies for instance had not had it's something that is quite novel and so the various kind of debates as to where henry might have got idea from it. And one thesis is that the Turks had used stakes like this with their archers against the knights at Nicopolis, the great disaster for Christian arms in 1396 that Marshal Boussacou had fought in,
指挥弓箭手，反映出亨利将经验放在了首位。他需要绝对可以信赖的人来为他保驾护航，在极度紧张和危险的环境下做出正确的举动。但与此同时，亨利在强调经验的同时，也并不害怕创新。这就是为什么在行军途中，他曾命令弓箭手们——尽管他们已经疲惫不堪、饥肠辘辘——自己动手做一些木桩，削尖木桩，连同其他所有装备一起随身携带。这是爱德华三世的军队以前所没有的，这是一种相当新颖的做法。因此，关于亨利可能从哪里得到这个灵感，存在各种各样的辩论。其中一种观点认为，土耳其人在1396年的尼科波利斯战役中曾对骑士使用过这种带木桩的弓箭手战术——那是基督教军队的一场大灾难，法国伟大的帕拉丁骑士布萨科曾参加过那场战役。我认为更可能的理论是，亨利是在回忆什鲁斯伯里战役。
the great French paladin. I think a likelier theory is that Henry is remembering the Battle of Shrewsbury. Right, because that was the pea field. The pea field with the stakes. Stakes there, right? Yeah. And of course, that was the battle where he'd been hit in the face by the arrow. Yeah. So a very traumatic and defining experience for him. So it makes sense that he would remember that.
没错，因为那是豌豆田之战。插着木桩的豌豆田。那里有木桩，对吧？是的。当然，那场战役中他曾被箭射中面部。是的。所以对他来说，这是一次非常痛苦且具有决定性的经历。因此他能记住这一点也就合情合理了。
Yeah, and it's, I think, important to emphasise that battles are rare events. Pitched battles are rare events. They don't come along very often. But Henry had experienced one when he was very, very young. And I think the memory of the role that these stakes had played, which of course weren't sharp because they were used for holding up peas, but they had prevented a mass charge by his father's men. I'm sure that probably this is where he gets the idea for it. And of course, the broader experience, as you said, that Henry had from Shrewsbury is being hit in the face by an arrow. So he knows what the impact is. I mean, he knows how devastating, you know, a hail storm of arrows can be.
是的，我认为必须强调的是，会战是罕见的事件。阵地战是罕见的事件。它们不会经常发生。但亨利在非常年轻的时候就经历过一次。我认为这些木桩所起作用的记忆——当然它们当时并不锋利，因为是用来支撑豌豆藤的，但它们确实阻止了他父亲部下的冲锋——我确信这大概就是他获得灵感的来源。当然，正如你所说，亨利从什鲁斯伯里战役中获得的更广泛的经验是面部中箭。所以他知道那种冲击力的影响。我的意思是，他深知箭雨的威力会有多大毁灭性。
And that's why I think it's based on the memories of that. You know, maybe he doesn't expect to win, but he feels he's in with a very, very good chance. But of course, he's not the only one with a plan. The French have a battle plan as well. And we know this because we actually have it. It's one of only a couple of battle plans to have survived from this period. This is amazing. Yeah, it's incredible.
这就是为什么我认为它是基于这些记忆做出的。你知道，也许他并没有指望能赢，但他觉得获胜的几率非常大。当然，并非只有他一个人有计划。法国人也有作战计划。我们之所以知道这一点，是因为我们确实保留了它。这是为数不多的从这一时期保存下来的作战计划之一。这太神奇了。是的，这难以置信。
So they put it down on paper or on parchment or whatever. by the two great professional soldiers in the French ranks. So Boussico, who we've mentioned, the great paladin, and Dalbray, who is the constable, the guy who kind of has a nominal control. But there are two problems with it. The first is that they'd actually drawn it up several days before and it doesn't exactly correspond to the terrain that you get at Agincourt. But the other problem is that they are no longer really in control. Their command has been superseded by the fact that large quantities of very high-ranking peers have turned up. So their original plan was to divide the army into two,
所以他们把它写在了纸上、羊皮纸上或其他什么东西上。由法国军队中的两位杰出的职业军人共同制定。一位是我们提到过的伟大的帕拉丁骑士布萨科，另一位是担任康斯塔贝尔（统帅）的达尔布雷，他是名义上的最高指挥官。但其中存在两个问题。第一个问题是，他们几天前就已经把它画好了，并不完全符合阿金库尔的实际地形。另一个问题是，他们实际上已经失去了控制权。他们的指挥权被大量涌入的高级贵族取代了。所以他们最初的计划是将军队分为两部分，
that the front rank would be commanded by Boussico and Dalbray as the professional soldiers, because they knew that they would be marching into the English arrow storm. And Dalbray in particular, he has fought the English. I mean, he's that old that he'd been part of the war back in Edward III's time and it's a slight myth isn't it that they take the English lightly because these guys they know that the English they remember the battles in the first bit of the hundred years war they know the Henry V he knows what he's doing they are not underestimating him right and in fact they didn't really want to battle at all is that right well I think they would have been perfectly happy not to fight a battle at all and just
前锋由布萨科和达尔布雷这两位职业军人指挥，因为他们知道自己将迎着英国人的箭雨行军。达尔布雷尤其如此，他与英国人交过手。我的意思是，他年纪那么大，曾参与过爱德华三世时期的战争，而且“法国人轻视英国人”其实是一个小小的神话，对吧？因为这些人了解英国人，他们还记得百年战争前半段的战役，他们知道亨利五世懂得他在做什么，他们绝对没有低估他，对吧？事实上，他们根本不想打仗，是这样吗？嗯，我想他们完全乐意不打仗，只是
let Henry's army disintegrate. They'd have been fine with that. They've been told basically by the king, by the Dauphin, by the peers of the realm, no, we have to fight. And so they've drawn up this plan where Boussicaut and Dalbray will command the vanguard. And then the second, the main body will be commanded by the Duke of Al alison you know who's this great kind of boar of a man they'll put crossbowmen on the wings and they will have an elite force of cavalry that will be used to clear the archers and it will be kind of total warfare dominic so the crossbowmen will fire the men at arms will charge the cavalry will sweep down on the archers and get rid of them and you know the english basically won't know what's hit them they'll be overwhelmed in a single devastating
让亨利的军队自行瓦解。他们完全可以接受这一点。国王、王太子以及王公贵族基本上告诉他们：“不，我们必须开战。”于是他们制定了这样一个计划：布萨科和达尔布雷将指挥先锋部队。然后第二部分，即主力部队，将由阿朗松公爵指挥——你知道的，这是一个身材魁梧、宛如野兽般的家伙——他们会在侧翼部署弩手，并拥有一支精锐骑兵部队，用来消灭弓箭手。这将是一场全面战争，多米尼克。所以弩手将进行齐射，重甲骑士将发起冲锋，骑兵将向弓箭手席卷而去并将其消灭，你知道的，英国人基本上会不知道自己是怎么挨打的，他们将在单一的、毁灭性的
moment of impact so kind of nelsonian go straight at them and use our firepower to blast them out of the way just everything throw everything you've got at them but the problem is because of the woods the cavalry is not in a position to march down and sweep the archers away so they can't outflank them so that's a problem but the other problem is is that because all these dukes and counts you know members of the royal family have arrived they outrank Boussico and Dalbray and because the king isn't there because the Dauphin isn't there because the Duke of Orléans who is the highest ranking royal member of the family, is there, but he's quite young. I mean, it's his birthday is in a couple of days. There isn't actually now an obvious commander. They're
冲击瞬间被压垮。这就有点像纳尔逊式的战术：直冲敌阵，用火力将对方炸个粉碎，把你们手头的一切都砸向他们。但问题是，由于树林的阻挡，骑兵无法冲过去消灭弓箭手，他们无法进行侧翼包抄，所以这是一个问题。另一个问题是，由于所有这些公爵、伯爵——也就是王室成员——的到来，他们的军衔高于布萨科和达尔布雷。而且由于国王不在，王太子不在，而奥尔良公爵这位王室中军衔最高的人虽然在场，但他相当年轻（他的生日就在几天后），因此现在实际上并没有一个显而易见的最高指挥官。他们
all kind of shouting and yelling and claiming precedence. They spend all night kind of basically arguing about where they should all go, because you've got all these dukes, all these counts, they're not going to hang around at the rear. want to be in the front so finally they come to a conclusion i quote juliet barker in her wonderful book on agincourt she says it's a conclusion that was fair but foolish and basically the solution is that they will all fight in the front line although alison will retain his command of the main body of the army behind them and this means that they have to lengthen the line to fit in all these peers and dukes which in turn means that there is no room for the archers and the crossbowmen so the solution to this is i will just get rid of them we'll put them at the back of
都在大喊大叫、争夺资历。他们整晚都在争论自己到底应该站在哪里，因为所有这些公爵、伯爵都不愿意待在后方，他们都想冲在最前面。最终他们得出了一个结论——我引用朱丽叶·巴克在她关于阿金库尔的精彩著作中的话，她说这是一个“公平但愚蠢”的结论。基本上，解决方案是他们都将在前线作战，尽管阿朗松将保留对他们身后军队主力的指挥权。这意味着他们必须拉长战线以容纳所有这些贵族和公爵，而这反过来又意味着根本没有空间容纳弓箭手和弩手。所以解决这个问题的办法就是：干脆把他们赶走，把他们放在军队的
of the army that's bonkers yeah that's bonkers so just before we go to the break tom i know this is very controversial among historians talk us through numbers, because for those of us who grew up in England reading kind of old-fashioned patriotic history books, the impression we were given was that for every hundred Frenchmen, there was one Englishman or something like that. But it is true, isn't it, that whatever historians think about the numbers, there are very, very different accounts. There is no doubt there are far more Frenchmen than there are Englishmen. Is that right? Well, so this has always basically been taken for granted and not just by English historians, by French historians as well. It's not just, you know, patriotic chauvinism that leads people to say that.
最后方。这太荒谬了。是的，这简直荒谬透顶。所以在大力休息之前，汤姆，我知道这在历史学家中是非常有争议的话题，跟我们聊聊人数吧。因为对于我们这些在英格兰长大地、读着老式爱德华七世风格的爱国历史书长大的人来说，我们留下的印象是：每有一百个法国人，就只有一个英国人左右。但不管历史学家对具体数字怎么看，确实存在着截然不同的记录，这一点千真万确，对吧？毫无疑问，法国人的数量远多于英国人。是这样吗？嗯，所以这基本上一直是理所当然的共识，不仅对英国历史学家如此，对法国历史学家也是如此。这不仅仅是人们常说的爱国沙文主义导致的。
The overwhelming body of the sources emphasise the fact that the English were very, very outnumbered. And it seems to me clear that, you know, we said this at the beginning of the show, that the reason why it has this resonance is because from the beginning, the English believe this. And to reiterate that, I would say the conventional estimate on the numbers of the English Stagion Corps is around 6,000 men. So 1,000 men at arms, about 5,000 archers. And this is based on the evidence of the two eyewitnesses at the battle who were on the English side. So the chaplain who we've mentioned, and there's also a Burgundian lord who was fighting with the English called Jean Lefebvre. And their estimates kind of, they balance out. But the reason
绝大多数历史资料都强调，英格兰人在数量上处于绝对的劣势。在我看来很明显的是，正如我们在节目开始时所说的那样，它之所以能引起如此强烈的共鸣，是因为从一开始，英国人就深信这一点。重申一下，我认为关于阿金库尔战役中英军人数的传统估计大约是6000人。其中1000名重甲骑士，大约5000名弓箭手。这基于身处英方阵营的两位战役目击者的证据。也就是我们提到过的随军牧师，还有一位名叫让·勒费夫尔的勃艮第领主，他当时与英军并肩作战。他们的估计结果大体相符。但之所以
why these figures have become controversial over the past 20 years is because Anne Currie, the great historian of the Agincourt campaign. And Herald, yeah. Yes. So she wrote this kind of game-changing book called Agincourt, A New History. It came out in 2005 and then it was reissued in 2015 for the anniversary of the battle. And she had gone through loads of primary sources. She'd looked at all the scrolls that no one had looked at since 1415 and so on. And she crunched the numbers. And she particularly focused on the recruitment and the composition of the various English contingents that went on the Agincourt campaign.
过去20年来这些数字会引发争议，是因为阿金库尔战役的伟大历史学家安·柯里（Anne Curry）。还有赫勒（Herald），是的。是的。她写了一本具有颠覆性的书，名为《阿金库尔：一部新史》（Agincourt: A New History）。该书于2005年出版，并在2015年战役周年纪念时再版。她查阅了大量的原始档案。她查看了自1415年以来无人问津的所有卷轴等等。她对数字进行了严密的统计。她特别关注了参加阿金库尔战役的各支英国分遣队的招募情况和人员构成。
And it's absolutely indispensable work. I mean, I've shamelessly drawn on it for these episodes. But it is also the controversy is that she uses these documents, these primary sources, to estimate that Henry's army had been maybe as high as 9,000. Actually, over the course of her book, her estimate of how large Henry's numbers were rises and rises and rises. And her estimate of the numbers of the French is that they're around 12,000. So that would be an imbalance of four to three. So the
这是绝对不可或缺的研究工作。我的意思是，我在这些节目中也厚颜无耻地借鉴了她的成果。但争议也在于，她利用这些文件、这些原始档案估计，亨利的军队人数可能高达9000人。事实上，在她的整本书中，她对亨利军队人数的估计一直在不断攀升。而她对法军人数的估计则在大约12000人左右。因此，这将会是一个四比三的不平衡比例。所以
French have a larger force, but it's not the kind of victory against overwhelming odds that tradition says it is. There has been, I think, quite a kind of kickback against that. So Juliette Barker in her book on Agincourt, I mean, she absolutely acknowledges, you know, there's no one who has a comparable knowledge of the minutiae of the financial administrative documents of the campaign. You know, Professor Currie is absolutely the leader on this. But she does kick back against it. And the reason that she does this is firstly looking at the French numbers. Basically, we don't know.
法军的兵力更强，但这并非传统说的那种以寡敌众的伟大胜利。我认为，对此已经出现了一种相当强烈的反弹。因此，朱丽叶·巴克在她关于阿金库尔的书籍中——我的意思是，她完全承认，没有人能拥有与她相比、对该战役财务行政文件细节的精细了解。柯里教授绝对是这方面的泰斗。但她的确对此进行了反弹。她之所以这么做，首先是审视了法军的人数。基本上，我们根本无从确切知晓。
We don't have the documents that would enable us to work it out because of the wars of religion, the French Revolution and so on. They were lost, right? They're all destroyed. Yeah, they've all just been lost. We just can't know. But the point she makes that does seem to me, I mean, maybe I want to believe it. I probably do want to believe it,
我们没有能够弄清楚这些的文书，因为宗教战争、法国大革命等等。它们都丢了，对吧？全都毁了。是的，它们都只是丢失了。我们根本无从知晓。但她提出的那一点，在我看来——我是说，也许我想相信它。我可能确实想相信它，
but it does seem to me really the clinching argument is that all the sources from the beginning emphasise that the victory is won against overwhelming odds. And I think that if Anne Currie's figures are accurate, that doesn't make sense. And I think that when you look at her figures, I mean, I think she said before, she's very much not Team Henry. She doesn't seem to like Henry very much at all. She has a tendency to make the English figures as high as she can and the French figures as low as she can. So I'm sure, Dominic, you, maybe lots of our listeners, maybe not our French listeners,
但这在我看来确实是最具决定性的论据，那就是所有从一开始的史料都强调，这场胜利是在处于绝对劣势的情况下赢得的。我认为，如果安·柯里的数据准确的话，那就说不通了。而且我认为，当你查看她的数据时——我的意思是，我想她之前说过，她非常不属于“亨利战队”。她似乎一点也不太喜欢亨利。她有一种倾向，尽量把英国人的数据写得尽可能高，把法国人的数据写得尽可能低。所以我敢肯定，多米尼克，你，也许我们的很多听众，也许不是我们的法国听众，
if we have any, but I think that they can listen to this and feel that the traditional account of the English being outnumbered, probably two to one, I would think. Maybe two to one, maybe at an extreme three to one. Tom, this is absolutely music to my ears. Absolute music to my ears. So to my ears so let's recap tom i'm what i'm taking from what you've just said is the english are outnumbered i sorry i should say the english and welch are outnumbered perhaps six seven eight to one tom is that what you're that what uh that's what you're saying uh probably two to one so ten to one odds a pinch three to one
如果我们有的话，但我认为他们听了这些之后会觉得，英国人处于劣势的传统说法，可能是一比二，我想。也许是一比二，极端情况下也许是一比三。汤姆，这简直是天籁之音。绝对的天籁之音。所以我听到这里，让我们总结一下，汤姆，我从你刚才的话中听到的意思是，英国人处于劣势，抱歉，我应该说英国人和威尔士人处于劣势，也许是六比一、七比一、八比一，汤姆，这就是你所说的那种——那正是你所说的吗？嗯，可能是一比二，所以是十比一的胜算，勉强算是一比三。
I think no more than that and on that bombshell we'll take a break and Tom we few we happy few we band of brothers we will be returning
我认为不会超过这个比例。带着这个爆炸性的消息，我们要休息一下。汤姆，我们少数人，我们这寥寥可数的幸运儿，我们这生死相依的兄弟，我们将会回归。
after a word from our advertisers to take on the French I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
听完广告商的一则短讯后，我们将迎战法国人。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐至上》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论的固定节目，
splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
还有各种娱乐圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及优先购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. It is dawn on the 25th of October, 1415. And if you'd been a bird flying over the field of Agincourt, you would have seen a man in a glittering crown on a little grey horse riding up and down this line of silver-clad men preparing Tom to step into the annals of legend. That's Henry V. Well, you say they're silver-clad, Dominic, but of course the English armour is pretty stained by this point with mud and rust.
欢迎回到《历史至上》。现在是1415年10月25日的黎明。如果你曾是一只飞越阿金库尔战场的鸟，你会看到一个头戴闪亮王冠的人骑着一匹小灰马，在这列身穿银甲、正准备踏入传奇史册的士兵队列中来回骑行，汤姆。那是亨利五世。嗯，你说他们身穿银甲，多米尼克，但当然，此时英国人的盔甲已经被泥土和锈迹弄得相当斑驳了。
They look like a rugby scrum. Yeah, there's quite a contrast with the French, who, of course, are much more spruce. But yes, Henry on his small grey horse, riding up and down the English lines, proclaiming the justice of his cause, appealing to the patriotism of his men, reminding them of the record of English armies in France, the victories won by Edward III, by the Black Prince, and making reference to boasts made by the French that if they capture archers, they will cut off two fingers from the right hand of every archer. Yeah.
他们看起来就像是一场橄榄球争球。是的，这与法国人形成了鲜明的对比，法国人显然要整洁得多。但是是的，亨利骑着他那匹小灰马，在英国人的阵列中来回骑行，宣扬他大义凛然，唤起士兵们的爱国主义精神，提醒他们英国军队在法国的辉煌战绩，即爱德华三世和黑太子赢得的胜利，并提到了法国人的狂言：如果他们抓住了弓箭手，就会砍掉每个弓箭手右手的两根手指。是的。
Which is where the myth that the V sign originates. Hold on. The myth? I don't think there's actually any evidence of that. Oh, this is disappointing. I mean, maybe, maybe it's much later, but certainly the readiness of the French to cut off the two fingers of the right arm of the bowman. Henry certainly makes reference to that. And so his men cheer him. Henry then sends his heralds to meet with the French heralds. You know, this is kind of like people shaking hands before a football match or something, effectively,
这就是V字手势起源的神话所在地。等等。神话？我认为实际上没有任何证据支持这一点。哦，这太令人失望了。我是说，也许，也许这是很久以后才有的，但法国人随时准备割掉弓箭手右手两根手指的这种做法是确凿无疑的。亨利肯定提到了这一点。所以他的士兵们为他欢呼。然后亨利派遣他的传令官去会见法国的传令官。你知道，这就有点像人们在足球比赛前握手之类的，实际上，
because obviously there is no chance of agreeing terms. The English herald returns. Henry dismounts from his horse, takes his place in the centre of the line. Banner is unfurled, crown on his head. There he is, facing him, the French lines. And again, I'll quote Juliet Barker. On one side stood row upon numberless row of motionless French men at arms, clad from head to foot in burnished armour, armed with swords and lances shortened for fighting on foot,
因为很明显，达成协议的机会为零。英国传令官回来了。亨利从马上下来，在队伍中央就位。旗帜展开，头戴王冠。他就站在那里，面对着他的是法国人的阵列。再次引用朱丽叶·巴克的话：“一边是数不清、密密麻麻、一动不动的法国重装步兵，他们全副武装，身穿打磨发亮的盔甲，手持剑和为步行作战而缩短的长枪，
and with brightly coloured pennons and banners waving over their heads. And it had actually been the expectation of the Royal Council that had been held at Rouen a few days before that the mere sight of this would be enough to send the english running away in terror but dominic they do the english run away in terror they know nothing of their bulldog spirit ever of an englishman yeah the metal so but obviously there's a you know as i said there's a tremendous contrast because the english look an absolute state, smeared in filth and dirt.
头顶上飘扬着色彩鲜艳的三角旗和旗帜。”实际上，几天前在鲁昂举行的皇家委员会的期望是，只要看到这一幕，就足以让英国人吓得仓皇逃窜了。但多米尼克，他们真的这么做了吗？英国人吓得逃跑了吗？他们对英国人的斗牛犬精神一无所知。是的，他们的骨气。但很明显，正如我所说，有一个巨大的对比，因为英国人的状态绝对糟糕透顶，身上涂满了污秽和脏东西。
And actually, Dominic, Juliet Barker has this glorious detail, which I also remember Robert Hardy, who was in... Winston Churchill. Yeah, he was always playing Winston Churchill. But he was very into longbows, kind of famous actor. I remember a documentary where he made the same point, that the archers at Agincourt have cut off their soiled britches so that if they need to void their bowels, and I guess that the sight of a large, fast army of French charging you might well make you loosen your bowels. You can just evacuate onto the muddy fields of France.
事实上，多米尼克，朱丽叶·巴克有一个极好的细节，我也记得罗伯特·哈迪曾演过……温斯顿·丘吉尔。对，他总是扮演温斯顿·丘吉尔。但他对长弓非常痴迷，是个相当著名的演员。我记得一部纪录片，他在片中也提出了同样的观点，即阿金库尔战役中的弓箭手们割开了他们肮脏的马裤，以便在他们需要排便时——我猜，看到一支庞大而快速的法国军队向你冲锋，很可能会让你放松肠胃——你可以直接排泄在法国泥泞的田野上。
Do you know, Tom, I'm thrilled to hear this because Sam Brock Jr., when he heard that we were doing this podcast, he said this to me about two days ago. Oh, you're going to put that detail in. Is that true? And I'm absolutely thrilled. It is true. But it also strikes me that the sight of, if you're a Frenchman, right, if you're used to the pampered living of early 15th century France, the sight of a gigantic Welshman with no trousers on.
你知道吗，汤姆，听到这个我太兴奋了，因为小萨姆·布洛克在听说我们要制作这个播客时，大约两天前就跟我说过这个了。哦，你要把这个细节写进去吗？这是真的吗？我感到非常兴奋。这确实是真的。但这也让我想到，如果你是一个法国人，对吧，如果你习惯了15世纪初法国养尊处优的生活，看到一个没有穿裤子的巨大壮硕的威尔士人——
Yes. Drinking his hairy legs. Voiling his hairy legs. Voiling his bowels out. I know. I know. No wonder they won. But there's something even worse, which is, again, as Juliette Ralfa points out, that this is an option not available to the men at arms, encased in their padded steel plate
是的。饮着他毛茸茸的腿。排泄着他毛茸茸的腿。大便失禁。我知道。我知道。难怪他们赢了。但还有更糟糕的事情，正如朱丽叶·拉尔法（译者注：即朱丽叶·巴克）所指出的那样，对于身穿厚重钢板盔甲的重装步兵来说，这是他们无法选择的选项。
armour. Grim though the sight of them must have been she writes the smell was probably worse now hold on i said in the first episode were they a bit ill you know have they got horrendous diarrhea and you said oh no no they're in great form but this suggests to me that some of them do have you know no they've been standing there well as we see they i mean they stand there for quite a long time as we will see right but also i, you obviously have nerves of steel. Yeah. But generally, if you're facing something terrifying, your bowels make churn. That's all I'm saying.
她写道，尽管他们的外表看起来已经够可怕了，但气味可能更糟。现在等等，我在第一集里说过，他们是不是有点生病？你知道，他们得了可怕的腹泻吗？你却说，哦不，哦不，他们的状态极佳。但这向我表明，他们中的一些人确实有……你知道的，没有，他们一直站在那里——正如我们所看到的，他们——我的意思是，他们站了很长一段时间，正如我们将要看到的，对吧？而且，你显然有钢铁般的意志。是的。但总的来说，如果你面对可怕的事情，你的肠胃可能会翻江倒海。我只想说这些。
So why is this an issue at Agincourt and not in other battles? Because we don't hear of similar things happening in other battles. I mean, do people do this in the, I don't know. They definitely didn't do this in the Battle of Britain, Tom. Sure. I've asked my brother that. I think it's bringing alive an aspect of medieval combat that perhaps is often underexplored. We're probing it. That's the word. We're probing it.
那为什么这在阿金库尔是个问题，而在其他战役中却不是呢？因为我们没有听说其他战役中发生过类似的事情。我是说，人们在……我不知道。他们在不列颠战役中绝对没有这样做，汤姆。当然。我问过我弟弟。我认为这生动展现了中世纪战斗的一个方面，而这个方面往往没有得到充分的探讨。我们在探究它。就是这个词。我们在探究它。
Right. And one of the reasons why they might be caught short is the fact that the battle lines are drawn up, but then nothing happens. Because as we've said, it's entirely in the French interest to just wait, you know, to see if the English line will disintegrate, to see how many more people will join them. And this insistence on waiting for reinforcements to come, you know, proves its worth because squadrons of horsemen and men at arms are coming in throughout the early hours of the 25th of October. So a classic example, kind of tragic example, is the Duke of Brabant, who's the brother of John the Fearless. He comes late. He's been having kind of brunch. He gets told the battle's happening. He goes, oh God, leaps on his horse, gallops up to the battle, hasn't had time to put his
没错。他们可能会被内急打个措手不及的原因之一是，战线已经拉开，但随后什么也没有发生。正如我们所说，静观其变完全符合法国人的利益，你知道的，看看英国人的防线是否会瓦解，看看会有多少人加入他们。这种坚持等待援军到来的做法，你知道的，证明了它的价值，因为骑兵中队和重装步兵在10月25日的清晨不断赶来。所以一个经典的例子，某种程度上是个悲剧性的例子，就是无畏约翰的兄弟布拉班特公爵。他来迟了。他一直在吃早午餐。有人告诉他正在打仗，他说，噢天哪，跳上马，骑马飞奔到战场，根本没有时间穿上
surcoat on. So he reaches for a banner, cuts a hole in it, puts it over his head, gallops into the battle and promptly gets taken prisoner. So that's a very tragic story. And his fate, as we will see, is properly tragic. But as we said also, the truth is probably Boussico and Dalbray, between them, would have been perfectly happy not to fight at all. It's all the French nobles who are itching to have a crack at the English. Anyway, so they stand facing each other for hour after hour. And this is why the toilet facilities is important. Right. Because you don't want to get caught short.
外衣。所以他顺手抓起一面旗帜，在上面剪了个洞，套在头上，骑马冲进战场，结果立刻被俘虏了。所以这是一个非常悲剧的故事。正如我们所见，他的命运确实是悲剧性的。但正如我们所说，事实可能也是布西考（Boucicaut）和达布雷（D'Albret）两人本来完全乐意根本不打仗。是所有的法国贵族都急不可耐地想跟英国人较量一番。无论如何，他们就这么面对面站着，一个小时又一个小时。这就是为什么厕所设施很重要。对吧。因为你不想被内急搞得措手不及。
And about 10 o'clock, Henry decides this is ridiculous. You know, we can't afford these delaying tactics. We have to get on with this. So he makes an amazing decision. He decides that even outnumbered as he is, he is going to have to get on with this. So he makes an amazing decision. He decides that even outnumbered as he is, he is going to have to make the first assault. So after the crossing of the Somme, this is the second of three moments of excruciating danger where everything might have just fallen to pieces. He orders the baggage train and non-combatants to assemble at the rear of the
到了10点左右，亨利觉得这太荒谬了。你知道的，我们经不起这种拖延战术。我们必须继续前行。于是他做出一个惊人的决定。他决定，尽管自己处于劣势，他也必须继续前进。所以他做出了一个惊人的决定。他决定，尽管自己处于劣势，他也必须发动第一轮进攻。因此，在渡过索姆河之后，这是三个极其危险时刻中的第二个，一切可能都已经分崩离析了。他下令将辎重列队和非战斗人员集结在战线后方，
battle line and to follow as they advance so that they won't be isolated and to draw the wagons up in a line so that their rear will be defendable. He then gives orders for the entire English line to advance. Every English soldier kneels, kisses the ground, and they do this thing where they take a piece of soil and put it in their mouth. And it's a kind of trusting themselves to God kind of thing. And they've done that. And then Henry gives the battle cry, St. George, this day, help thine own. Massive cheer. And they start advancing. But this is the moment of peril, because for the archers, who are maybe five-sixths of the entire army, you know, they are basically defenceless at this point. They have to pull their stakes up, move forward,
并在他们前进时随行，以免他们被孤立，并把马车排成一线，以便他们的后方可以防守。然后他下令整条英国战线向前推进。每个英国士兵都跪下，亲吻地面，他们还做了一个动作，抓起一把泥土放进嘴里。这是一种将自己托付给上帝的仪式。他们做完了这些。然后亨利发出战吼：“圣乔治，今天保佑你自己的子民。”巨大的欢呼声响起。他们开始前进。但这正是最危险的时刻，因为对于弓箭手来说——他们可能占了整支军队的五分之四——你知道的，此时他们基本上毫无防守能力。他们必须拔起木桩，向前移动，
hammer the stakes back in. And the whole time, if the French cavalry had charged, they would have been in no position to fire back. They would have just been overwhelmed. So for Henry, this is, I mean, you can imagine it. His heart must have been in his mouth. Why didn't the French charge? Yeah, what's going on?
再把木桩砸进土里。而在这整个过程中，如果法国骑兵发起冲锋，他们将完全无法还手。他们只会被彻底摧毁。所以对亨利来说，这意味着——你可以想象得到。他的心当时一定提到了嗓子眼。为什么法国人没有冲锋？是的，到底怎么回事？
I think because they're taken by surprise. They can't believe that the English would have the nerve to advance on them. And so, you know, they're not on their horses. They're not in the front line. They're not ready to go. And this is an absolute disastrous failure on the French part because the French line is now within the range of the English longbows. And Sir Thomas Irpingham, who is the old veteran who's in charge of the archers, he's got this baton and he throws it in the air as a signal that they should unleash their first volley.
我想是因为他们被打了个措手不及。他们简直不敢相信英国人竟然有胆量向他们发起冲锋。所以，你知道的，他们当时不在马上。不在前线。还没有准备好行动。这是法国人的一次绝对灾难性的失误，因为英国人的战线现在已经进入了英国长弓的射程之内。老老兵、负责弓箭手的托马斯·厄平汉爵士（Sir Thomas Erpingham）手里拿着一根指挥棒，他把它抛向空中，作为发射第一轮齐射的信号。
And this is what they do. So in the first minute, 75,000 arrows rain down on the French lines. And by this point on the French lines. And by this point, the French cavalry have got their act together and are charging. And they are charging into darkness because these arrows, you know, they blot out the sun. And there's no need for the English to kill the knights. The developments in armour are so impressive that most of the arrows just kind of bounce off the plate. But what they need to do is to knock right the knights off their horses and the sheer volume of arrows descending in this kind of storm is more than sufficient to do that or of course to bring the horses down yeah 75 000 arrows i mean you can't imagine it can you i mean i can imagine 700 arrows i'm not sure i can imagine 7,000 arrows coming
他们就是这么做的。所以在第一分钟里，7万5千支箭如雨点般落在法国人的阵地上。而此时，法国骑兵已经组织起来并开始冲锋。他们是在黑暗中冲锋，因为这些箭，你知道的，把太阳都遮蔽了。英国人根本不需要杀死骑士。盔甲的发展如此惊人，以至于大多数箭射到板甲上都只是弹开了。但他们需要做的是把骑士从马上撞下来，这种狂风暴雨般倾泻而下的巨大箭量，完全足够做到这一点，或者当然也可以把马匹射倒。是的，7万5千支箭——我的意思是，你简直无法想象，对不对？我的意思是，我可以想象700支箭，但我不敢确定我能不能想象7000支箭从天而降，
out of the sky at maybe 75,000. I mean, that is, and they're coming at such a speed and they, I mean, they're heavy, right? They've got bits of steel or whatever it is on the end and all of that. Yeah. So the technology of arrowheads has developed. They're much, much, I can't remember exactly why, but it's to do with the weighting and the serration of the arrowhead. It means that they are much more lethal in their effects, as of course, Henry knows. And Henry, unlike Percy at the Battle of Shrewsbury, has made sure that there are plentiful supplies of arrows. The English can just keep firing and firing and firing. And you have knights who are knocked off into the mud, or you have horses that are shot. Wounded horses start kind of careering round, maybe charging back into the battle line behind them or impaling themselves
数量可能达到75,000支。我的意思是，那是……而且它们是以极高的速度飞来的，它们很重，对吧？它们的尖端有钢铁碎片或其他什么东西，诸如此类。是的。所以箭头的技术已经得到了发展。它们变得重得多，重得多——我不记得具体原因了，但这与箭头的重量分配和锯齿状边缘有关。这意味着它们造成的杀伤力要致命得多，正如亨利当然知道的那样。而且亨利不像什鲁斯伯里战役中的珀西那样，他确保了有充足的箭矢供应。英国人可以不停地射击，不停地射击，不停地射击。你会看到骑士被撞落到泥潭里，或者战马被射中。受伤的马匹开始疯狂乱奔，可能会冲回它们身后的战线，或者把自己刺穿在木桩上。我的意思是，绝对惨不忍睹。
on stakes. I mean, absolutely hideous. And amazingly, the casualties among the horsemen themselves seem to have been relatively light. And a lot of them just kind of crawl their way out of the mud and draw, and they're later charged with cowardice. But the impact of the failure of their charge to reach the archers is most devastating on the men at arms who were drawn up behind them and who are now advancing in turn. And the reason for this is that they have churned up the ground. They've got frightened horses knocking into them the combination of this means that it is really really difficult for them to advance towards the line of english and all the time the arrows are still raining down on them and is it true which what i read as a boy that
令人惊奇的是，骑兵自身的伤亡似乎相对较轻。他们中的许多人只是从泥潭里爬出来逃跑了，后来他们被指控为懦夫。但他们的冲锋未能到达弓箭手的毁灭性影响，对那些在他们身后列阵、现在正轮流向前推进的重装步兵来说却是最致命的。原因在于，地面已经被他们踩得泥泞不堪。受惊的马匹撞击着他们，所有这些因素结合在一起，意味着他们要想向前推进到英国人的阵线上简直难如登天，而与此同时，箭矢仍然如雨点般倾泻在他们身上。
when you fall down in this mud this sort of pasturechendaele, the Battle of the Somme scene, this quagmire, that if you fall down in your armour, your armour is so heavy that you can't get up again. Is that true? Yeah. And if the mud is of sufficient liquidity in due course, there's a serious chance that you will drown if you can't move. So it's pretty hideous. And the time it takes for the French men-at-arms to reach the English line, if it was solid ground, it would be no time at all. But because the ground is so churned up, because there are all these horses rushing everywhere, because the arrows are falling, because they have to keep their eyes lowered to ensure that they don't get hit through the visor or whatever. It takes them maybe five to 10 minutes to cross
这是否属实呢？我小时候读到过，当你倒进这种泥地里——比如帕斯尚尔战役、索姆河战役那种场景，这种泥沼——如果你穿着盔甲倒下，你的盔甲太重了，以至于你再也站不起来了。这是真的吗？是的。如果泥浆达到一定的流动性，在适当时机，如果你无法动弹，你会有很大的溺水风险。所以这相当可怕。法国重装步兵到达英国阵线所需的时间，如果是坚实的地面，那根本花不了多少时间。但由于地面如此泥泞不堪，由于到处都是乱冲的战马，由于箭矢不断落下，由于他们必须压低视线以确保面甲等部位不被击中，他们可能需要花上5到10分钟才能穿过这段距离。
the gap. And by the time they reach the English lines, those who do manage to reach the English lines, I mean, they are shattered. Their armour is very, very heavy. And to be slopping through all this kind of hideous, thick, viscous mud, they are completely exhausted by the time they reach the English line. And adding to the quality of nightmare that they must have found themselves in, they are being funneled. Because remember, the trees draw in towards the English line, and they're being shot at from the wings. So the instinctive reaction, no matter how brave you are, of course, is to bunch up away from the two sides
而当他们到达英国人的阵线时——那些确实成功到达英国阵线的人，我的意思是，他们已经筋疲力尽了。他们的盔甲非常非常重。还要在所有这种可怕、厚重、粘稠的泥浆中艰难跋涉，当他们到达英国阵线时，已经彻底精疲力竭了。为了增加他们所陷入的那种噩梦般的体验，他们正在被漏斗状地聚拢。因为记住，树木向英国人的防线收拢，他们正从侧翼遭到射击。所以，无论你有多勇敢，本能的反应当然是避开两侧，往中间挤作一团。
in the middle. And then on top of that, remember, Henry has this crown, he has his banner, he's situated himself in the middle. He is offering himself up as bait. He's saying, come and get me. And so the consequence of this is the French lines are so tightly compressed that it's very difficult for many of them even to raise their arms. And even if they do have room to raise their arms, many of them are so exhausted by this point that they can't really move. So this becomes your classic crush, right? They're in a crush in the mud. Yes. And actually the arrows are raining down on them all the time. And ahead of them, they've got blokes with no trousers on who are soiling themselves. Yeah. Avoiding their bowels,
不仅如此，记住，亨利戴着王冠，打着旗帜，他把自己安置在中央。他把自己当成了诱饵。他在说：“来抓我呀。”因此，这样做的结果是，法国人的阵线被压缩得如此紧密，以至于他们中的许多人甚至很难抬起手臂。即使他们有空间抬起手臂，他们中的许多人此时也已经精疲力竭，以至于无法真正移动。所以这就成了你们典型的踩踏事件，对吧？他们在泥地里发生了挤压踩踏。是的。事实上，箭雨一直不断地落在他们头上。而在他们前方，是一群没有穿裤子、大便失禁的家伙。是的。排泄着他们的肠子，
left, right and centre. And of course, the winds are gusting, so it's spraying into their face. Yeah, it's kind of chemical warfare at its worst. And so with all of these horrors manifesting themselves on the battlefield, I think it is really impressive that actually enough French men-at-arms reach the English line, that the crunch is pretty pulverising.
左边、右边、中间到处都是。当然，风还在阵阵刮过，所以这都喷溅到了他们的脸上。是的，这简直是最糟糕的化学战。因此，随着所有这些恐怖场景在战场上显现，我认为非常令人印象深刻的是，实际上有足够多的法国重装步兵到达了英国阵线，那场碰撞可以说是极具毁灭性的。
Tom, it's lovely that you're being so generous to the French. So I talked about the two previous moments of excruciating peril faced by Henry's army, the Somme and when they advance. This is the third. Because remember, there are only a thousand English men at arms. It's a very thin line. And if that line had broken, Henry would still have lost the battle. The French would have redeemed triumph from seeming disaster. But the English line holds. So you were saying, sorry, I interrupted you. There was a huge crunch and they drive the English back a bit, don't they? Is that right? Yeah. So it's like a kind of rugby scrum, I guess, kind of smashing into a much weaker, smaller scrum, kind of pushes it back. But then the English line holds. And it's the
汤姆，你对法国人如此慷慨，真是太好了。我之前谈到了亨利军队面临的两次极其危险的时刻：索姆河以及他们前进的时候。这是第三次。因为记住，英国重装步兵只有一千人。这是一条非常单薄的防线。如果那条防线被突破，亨利仍然会输掉这场战役。法国人本可以从看似灾难的境地中挽回胜利。但英国人的防线顶住了。所以你刚才在说——抱歉，我打断了你。发生了一次巨大的碰撞，他们把英国人击退了一点，对吗？是这样吗？是的。所以这有点像橄榄球争球，我猜，猛烈撞击到一个弱得多、小得多的乌合之众般的阵型上，把它往回推了一点。但随后英国防线顶住了。正是英国防线顶住了这一事实，使得英国人的胜利成为可能。
fact the English line holds that makes the English victory possible. And Henry's chaplain, who is at the back, he's a non-competent, but he's close enough. He can see what's going on. I mean, he's full of praise for this. He wrote later, never, it seemed to our older men, had Englishmen ever fallen upon their enemies more boldly and fiercely or with a better will. And so the melee is incredibly ferocious, but the English amazingly, despite being so outnumbered, have the advantage for all the reasons that we've discussed. The arrows are still falling down. The French are compacted. They're exhausted. And of course, also what is starting to happen is that great piles of bodies are starting to mount up, particularly in front of the position of the king, because all the French lords want to have a crack at him. Gloucester,
亨利的随军牧师当时在后方，他是个非战斗人员，但他离得够近，能看到发生了什么。我的意思是，他对这一点赞不绝口。他后来写道：“在我们的老兵看来，英国人从未如此大胆、凶猛或带着如此高昂的斗志向敌人发起进攻。”因此，混战异常残酷，但英国人非常惊人，尽管人数处于巨大劣势，却由于我们讨论过的所有原因而占据了优势。箭雨仍在下落。法国人被挤压在一起。他们筋疲力尽。当然，开始发生的情况是，大量尸体积聚起来，特别是在国王的位置前方，因为所有的法国领主都想跟他过两招。格洛斯特，
his youngest brother, Humphrey, he's never fought in a battle before he is bloodied when a sword is jabbed through his groin oh my god king stands over him defending his brother you know absolute scenes part of his crown is hacked off so they really are going after the king but actually the main focus of the French line seems to have been on the right wing for reasons that are not entirely clear because York is killed there, 86 of his men with him. And this seems to be where the fighting is at its most brutal and hard, but it's brutal and hard along the entire length of the battle line. But increasingly, as the minutes turn to hours, effectively it is becoming a bloodbath because the French are in no position except to just stand there or perhaps lie there and be slaughtered. And the measure of this is that archers start to sneak out from their positions, from behind their stakes.
他的小弟汉弗莱，以前从未打过仗，当一把剑刺入他的腹股沟时，他负伤了。天哪！国王站在他身上面对敌人保护他的弟弟，场面极其震撼。他的王冠的一部分被砍掉了，所以他们真的是冲着国王去的。但实际上，法国阵线的主要焦点似乎是在右翼，原因并不完全清楚，因为约克公爵在那里阵亡，他有86名士兵与他一同倒下。这似乎是战斗最残酷、最惨烈的地方，但沿着整条战线，战斗都同样残酷而惨烈。然而随着时间的推移，分分秒秒过去，这里实际上变成了一场屠杀，因为法国人除了站在那里，或者也许躺在那里任人宰割之外，已经别无选择。衡量这一点的一个标准是，弓箭手开始从他们的阵地、从他们的木桩后面偷偷溜出来。
And they have mallets, you know, which they use to hammer in their stakes. And they use these mallets to knock over the French. I mean, it's kind of like knocking over a ten pin with a ball. And they just, you know, the men at arms just kind of keel over and then the bowmen will draw out their swords, their daggers and plunge it in through the eye sockets or through the kind of the gap in the neck. And so it's commented of the casualties in this battle that the vast majority perish of wounds to the eyes or to the neck and it's at this point that people are drowning isn't it because in the crush the crush of bodies corpses horses all the chaos the mud frenchmen are falling and just never getting up again because they're being suffocated by the mud
他们拿着木槌——这是他们用来钉木桩的工具。他们用这些木槌把法国人敲倒。我的意思是，这有点像用球击倒保龄球瓶。他们只是——你知道的，重装步兵就这样向前扑倒，然后弓箭手会拔出他们的剑、匕首，从眼窝或脖子的空隙处刺进去。因此，关于这场战役中的伤亡情况，人们评论说，绝大多数人都是死于眼睛或脖子上的伤势。正是在这个时候，人们被淹死了，对吧？因为在拥挤的人群中——尸体、战马的拥挤，所有的混乱和泥泞中，法国人不断倒下，再也没有站起来，因为他们被泥土和尸体的重量窒息了。
and the weight of bodies yeah and the english realize this and this is why they keep knocking them over so thomas walsingham our friend the monk in saint auburn's he clearly picking up on eyewitness reports and he says the french stood immobilized whilst our men wrenched axes from their hands and felled them as if they were cattle. And this goes on for three hours, Tom? It basically goes on for three hours. I mean, it's an enormous, yeah. Imagine how exhausting. It's hideous. Just the mud, the blood, just awful, awful, awful yeah hideous and yet somehow oddly rousing
是的，英国人意识到了这一点，这就是为什么他们不断把他们敲倒。所以我们的朋友、圣奥尔本斯的僧侣托马斯·沃尔辛厄姆（Thomas Walsingham），他显然是从目击者的报告中得知这一情况的，他写道：“当我们的士兵从他们手中夺过战斧并像砍伐牲畜一样将他们砍倒时，法国人却呆立不动。”这种情况持续了三个小时，汤姆？基本上持续了三个小时。我的意思是，这是一个巨大的——是的。想象一下那是多么精疲力竭。太可怕了。到处都是泥浆、鲜血，简直糟糕、糟糕、糟糕透顶——是的，太可怕了，然而不知为何又隐隐让人热血沸腾。
well as we'll see i think even the english are kind of stunned and some of them are distressed by the scale of the slaughter but we're in the final episode we'll look at reactions to the battle but just to finish off the account of the battle itself, basically it's over by one o'clock. The flower of French chivalry is either dead or taken prisoner. So the English have taken lots of prisoners and Henry seems to have his victory. But then there comes one final twist, probably the most controversial moment in Henry's reign, features in Shakespeare's play. And essentially what happens is that Henry thinks he's won, and then a cry goes up from the rear that the French are rallying and are about to launch another attack and that they're attacking the wagons. So Henry thinks he's surrounded.
嗯，正如我们所看到的，我认为甚至英国人都有些震惊，其中一些人对这场屠杀的规模感到痛心。但我们将在最后一集里探讨对这场战役的反应。不过，为了结束对战役本身的叙述，基本上到一点钟时战斗就结束了。法国骑士精神的精华要么阵亡，要么被俘。所以英国人抓了大量的俘虏，亨利似乎赢得了他的胜利。但随后出现了一个最后的转折，这可能是亨利统治时期最具争议的时刻，也出现在莎士比亚的戏剧中。基本上发生的情况是，亨利以为自己赢了，然后后方传出一声大喊，称法国人正在重新集结，准备发动另一次进攻，并且他们正在袭击马车。所以亨利以为自己被包围了。
And this is a massive crisis. It's clear that people have broken in through the wagons and they are making off with all his treasures. So his crown, so not the one on his helmet, but his other one. Yeah. Lots of jewels, a kind of jeweled scepter, sword of state, a piece of the true cross. I mean, terrible for Henry. And so Henry thinking, you know, my men are exhausted. We're still outnumbered. He gives the very controversial that all the prisoners that have been taken should be killed. And his men are very reluctant to obey this order, partly because obviously that, you know, for pecuniary reasons, a dead prisoner can pay no ransom. But also because this is very
这是一场巨大的危机。很明显，有人已经冲破了马车防线，正带着他所有的宝物逃跑。所以他的王冠——不是他头盔上的那个，而是他的另一个。是的，大量的珠宝，一根镶嵌珠宝的权杖，国剑，一块真十字架的碎片。我的意思是，对亨利来说太糟糕了。因此，亨利认为——你知道的，我的士兵们筋疲力尽了。我们仍然寡不敌众。他下了一个极具争议的命令：所有被俘的战俘都必须被处死。他的士兵们非常不情愿地服从这个命令，部分原因显然是——你知道的，出于金钱上的考虑，一个死囚索要不到赎金。但也是因为这太令人震惊了。毫无疑问，他们在道义上有负罪感。这违背了骑士法，违背了基督教教义。但亨利还是这么做了。令人惊奇的是，法国历史学家实际上从未因此指责过他。他们似乎接受了他做了他不得不做的事。他是一个强硬的人，一个冷酷无情的人，他为了让军队继续前进，做他不得不做的事。
shocking. I mean, undoubtedly they have moral qualms about it. It's against the laws of chivalry. It's against Christian teaching. But Henry does it anyway. And what's amazing is that he's never actually blamed for this by French chroniclers. They seem to have accepted that he did what he had to do. He's a hard man. He's a ruthless man. And he does what he has to do to keep his army going.
他必须这么做，因为如果他们正遭受后方的夹击，并且在他们中间有数百名法国人，你知道的，法国人一旦有机会就会反咬他们一口。所以他们必须除掉……这就是他的想法，对吧？所以你想想看，如果你面对更多的敌人从正面进攻，他们又在绕向你的后方，而你的阵地中又有大量身穿全套盔甲的法国人，
He has to do it because if they are being attacked from the rear as well and they have in their midst this kind of, you know, hundreds or whatever of Frenchmen, you know, the Frenchmen will just turn on them as soon as they get the chance. So they have to get rid of... That's his thinking, is it? So if you think about it, if you've got more of the enemy coming frontally, they're coming round the rear, and you have large bodies of Frenchmen in full armour in your own positions,
那么如果他们全部联手，你就会被彻底消灭。因此，再次引用朱丽叶·巴克的话，她说这是唯一可行的命令。我认为就战术和战略而言，她是正确的。从道德上讲，这仍然是亨利声誉上的一个污点，但我认为当时的背景清楚地表明了他为什么要这么做。而讽刺的是，事实上这个谣言并不是真的。法国人并没有重新集结，袭击辎重队的也不是士兵，他们可能是当地人，抓住了机会（去抢夺）——你知道的，带着王冠和一块真十字架碎片逃跑，对吧？（笑）你知道的，一些珠宝之类的东西，他们只是某种当地的拦路强盗之类的，顺手牵羊拿走了王冠珠宝。是的，好吧，我想他们大概是当地人，心想，好吧，你知道的，我们的庄稼全都彻底毁了，是的，让我们从这桩买卖中捞点好处吧。但很显然，谋杀战俘增加了战役的死亡人数。这也增加了阵亡贵族的人数，对同时代的人来说，这可能是整场战役中最令人震惊的方面。所以他们都死了。很明显，法国人不会再发动进攻了。
then if they all combine, you're just going to be obliterated. So, quote Juliet Barker again, she says this was the only order possible. And I think in terms of tactics and strategy, she's right. I mean, morally, it remains a blot on Henry's escutcheon, but I think the context of the time makes it clear why he does it. And the irony is, is that actually the rumor wasn't true. The French are not rallying and the people who have attacked the baggage train are not soldiers they're probably locals who have seized their chance to you know to make off with a crown and a bit of the true cross right you know some jewels and stuff they're just um sort of local foot pads or something helping themselves to the crown jewels yeah well i think they're probably locals who think well you know we've had all our harvest has been absolutely ruined yeah let's try and get something out of this business. But obviously the murder of the prisoners adds to the death toll of the battle. And it adds to the number of magnates who are killed, which for contemporaries is perhaps the most shocking aspect of the whole battle. So they're dead. It becomes clear that there isn't going to be another French attack. And
战斗以非常正式的方式结束了。法国传令官走近亨利，亨利说：“你承认我的胜利吗？我赢了吗？”传令官说：“是的，你知道的，我们认输了。”然后亨利问道，他环顾四周，看到一座城堡在树林上方拔地而起，他说：“那座城堡叫什么名字？环绕它的村庄叫什么名字？”他被告知那是阿金库尔（Agincourt，英语发音），或者实际上法语发音是阿赞库尔（Azincourt）。一位勃艮第编年史家记录了亨利的回应：“因为，”国王说，“所有的堡垒、村庄或城镇的名字，都应当以距离它们最近的战斗发生地点来命名。这场战役将从现在到永远被称为阿金库尔战役。”
the battle ends very formally. The French herald approaches Henry and Henry says, do you accept my victory? Have I won? And the herald says, yes, you know, we concede. And then Henry asks, he looks around and he sees a castle rising up over the trees. And he says, what is the name of that castle? What is the name of the village that surrounds it? And he's told that it is Agincourt or actually Agincourt in French. And a Burgundian chronicler reports Henry's reply. And because, said the king, all battles ought to bear the names of the nearest fortress, village, or town to the place where they were fought. This battle will now and forever be known as the Battle of Agincourt.
这场战斗以非常正式的方式结束。法国先驱使者走近亨利，亨利问，你接受我的胜利吗？我赢了吗？使者说，是的，你知道，我们认输了。然后亨利问，他环顾四周，看到一座城堡在树木上方拔地而起。他说，那座城堡叫什么名字？它周围的村庄叫什么名字？有人告诉他那是阿金库尔，实际上法语里叫阿金库尔。一位勃艮第编年史家记录了亨利的回应。国王说，因为所有战役都应该以它们发生地点最近的要塞、村庄或城镇的名字命名，这场战役现在并将永远被称为阿金库尔战役。
Tom, wonderful stuff. Absolutely wonderful stuff. From this day to the ending of the world, we who did this podcast shall be remembered. So, everybody, we will return next time for the final episode in this series. We'll discuss the casualty figures. We'll talk about what happens to the people taken prisoner. We'll talk about the aftermath of the battle and henry's determination to make himself king of france
汤姆，精彩绝伦的内容。绝对精彩绝伦。从今天直到世界末日，我们这些制作了这个播客的人都将被世人铭记。所以，各位，我们下次将回归本系列的最后一集。我们将讨论伤亡数字；我们将讨论被俘人员的命运；我们将讨论战役的余波以及亨利决心让自己成为法国国王的决心，
as well as england and we will look at what happens at the end of his reign and we'll discuss tom we'll have a little chat won't we about henry v's reputation and his legacy and where he stands today because i know that some, perhaps associated with this podcast, have in the past said foolish things about Henry V for which they will be wanting to apologise. So on that bombshell, we will see you for the tumultuous and decisive final episode of this series next time.
不仅是英格兰国王。我们还将探讨他统治末期发生的事情，我们还要讨论——汤姆，我们要聊一聊，对吧？——关于亨利五世的名声、他的遗产以及他今天的地位。因为我知道有些人，也许与这个播客有关的人，过去曾对亨利五世说过愚蠢的话，他们会为此想要道歉。带着这个爆炸性的消息，我们下期节目将迎来本系列喧嚣而又具决定性的最终回，期待与大家相见。
Of course, if you're a member of the Rest Is History Club, you hear it now. If you're not, therestishistory.com is the place to go to. And on that bombshell, au revoir. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
当然，如果你是“历史至上”俱乐部（The Rest Is History Club）的会员，你现在就能听到它。如果你还不是，therestishistory.com就是你要去的地方。带着这个爆炸性的消息，奥雷瓦尔（再见）。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、各种娱乐圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及优先购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。